no
[Música]
bueno pues bienvenidos a tdx y
curiosamente yo tengo un tema que tiene
mucho que ver con de sal aquí enfrente
no ese miedo ese temor esa ansiedad que
a veces nos lleva a cometer errores pero
son errores totalmente humanos lo que a
veces no podemos entender o esperamos y
alguien que aquí está enfrente es la
perfección hay algo que deben de
entender dentro de la comunicación ok
esto clave no es de otra manera no somos
perfectos y los que nos están viendo
para los oradores que algún día llegan a
estar aquí tampoco son perfectos los
asistentes
es decir vivimos en la imperfección de
la comunicación lo único que podemos
hacer mejor es dar nuestro mejor
esfuerzo pero de ahí viene todo de dar
nuestro mejor esfuerzo así que estar
aquí en frente viene con este tema que
curiosamente me toca darles y que muy
contento lo voy a hacer por supuesto
habilidades y ventajas de ser un buen
comunicador bueno es un tema un poco
difícil porque esta lectura que ustedes
ven de ahí quiere decir que el que está
enfrente si no es bueno pues entonces es
un mentiroso no se me va a salir una
grosería a veces yo suelo decir mucho
unas conferencias pero te lo tiene
prohibido entonces ahora si está aquí
tengo que aguantarme bueno este tema
tiene mucha importancia no solamente no
solamente en ser un conferencista si a
veces nos da miedo llegar a casa para no
hablar con nuestras novias o esposas
ahora imagínense estar aquí enfrente es
un terror impresionante estar aquí
enfrente y requiere de mucha de mucha
habilidad vale se puede se puede lograr
esto no esté yo no nací para eso a mí no
me sale si se capacitan si se entrenan
todos lo pueden lograr va bien ese es el
primer concepto ahora quienes están
obligados a saber comunicarse todos
todos los seres humanos tenemos que
comunicarnos nada de que yo soy abogado
no me tengo que comunicar yo soy doctor
no me tengo que comunicar hasta nuestros
propios animales mascotas aprenden a
comunicarse con nosotros si nos han
visto no cuando su perrito les pide
comida como se les queda viendo y
deshace ojitos casi postores bueno esa
es comunicación de los animales hacia
nosotros a veces ellos
única de mejor manera que nosotros como
seres humanos eso es una barbaridad
porque me da tanto tiempo comunicarme en
público hace curiosamente hace poquito
escuché en una conferencia que decían
que como sentirse como sentirnos como
mexicanos porque también mexicano
orgullosos de nuestra historia no de
donde sacamos esa valentía y ese coraje
para poder pararnos aquí enfrente y
poder exponerlos absolutamente a todos
ustedes no hay héroes nacionales no hay
muchos entonces al no tener esos héroes
nacionales nos vamos un poco más hacia
atrás hacia el origen del temor del
miedo de ese pánico que genera estar
aquí enfrente y el temor a no ser un
líder se lo resumo conquista en américa
la conquista de américa todavía la
venimos arrastrando pero arrastrando y
eso hace que nos den miedo muchísimas
cosas estar aquí enfrente créanme que
bajo los valores de imposición castigo y
sumisión no hay no son elementos el
liderazgo que puedan hacer que se paren
en este punto en este punto rojo y
entonces proyecten lo que quieren
proyectar a todos de una forma segura
es imposible a veces desafortunadamente
la programación infantil escolar que
recibimos aquí en méxico es la principal
culpable de que de que de nuestra
desgracia de que no seamos personas
seguras eso es una verdadera desgracia y
esperemos que eso vaya cambiando vale
crítica
prácticamente todo se resume en crítica
estar aquí enfrente que van a pensar en
estoy estoy gordito este tengo el cierre
abajo ya ya sé mi discusión este bueno
se ponen a pensar en mil cosas menos en
su conferencia y eso evidentemente hace
qué carambas se van a poder concentrar
en su presentación siendo que están
pensando es si traen el cierre abajo o
no
contraigo abajo reducirle pasando es
broma entonces prácticamente todo se
concentra en la crítica en cómo no se
está criticando la gente que nos está
escuchando ahora esto no solamente es
estando aquí en frente vale es en el
trabajo es con nuestra familia es con
nuestros hijos cómo podemos pararnos
frente a nuestros padres si ellos nos
han hablado toda la historia de que
ellos una máxima autoridad y en puntos
donde no estamos de acuerdo como hijos
no podemos debatir les porque ellos una
máxima autoridad ahora es un mes lo malo
es lo grave lo grave es que esa
educación la transferimos al trabajo
seguramente saben que es programación
infantil verdad si no lo saben son todas
esas ideas con las que han criado o nos
han criado o han criado a sus hijos la
famosa frase cállate que los adultos
están hablando a alguien se lo ha dicho
supongo que a sus hijos bueno resulta
que ese niño
dieguito de 6 años crece se vuelve un
ejecutivo está por por el compadre
porque la única manera que haya llegado
a ser ejecutivo está en esa reunión de
trabajo y tiene que exponer
sus puntos de vista y en esa reunión de
gabinete de trabajo le preguntan ya
quitó tú qué opinas tú qué opinas de
este tema y le quito
no sé como una gelatina ahí enfrente y
por qué le pasa eso a dieguito porque
toda su familia o sus papás le dijeron
cállate que los adultos están hablando y
cuando el niño tiene que pedir oye quito
ya diego señor papá abuelo tal vez tiene
que hablar nos salen las palabras porque
no no lo criaron para eso está pensando
chiquito en la crítica vale bueno
ahorita vamos a hablar de qué
habilidades deben de tener para poder
ser buenos comunicadores en esta imagen
hay algo muy curioso que quiero
mostrarles ustedes pues pueden pensar
que están aquí enfrente y se ven
espectaculares y están haciendo lo
correcto que se ven como dioses pero la
proyección de su cuerpo es totalmente
sumisa y la reacción que tiene la gente
con nosotros es sumisa ahí pueden ver en
la cara de la niña una sonrisa incómoda
ante la pena y sumisión que muestra el
caballero
su misión el perrito sumiso para que
vean que absolutamente todos hasta los
animales proyectamos con nuestro
lenguaje verbal y no verbal lo que
sentimos eso comunica
habilidades aquí es donde voy a tratar
de darles unos tips rápidamente para que
todos en algún momento si lo necesitan
pues adelante las esposas no me vayan a
odiar por favor porque a veces los
hombres utilizan esto para ligar y me
andan persiguiendo por la calle entonces
por favor no se me vaya en el cuello el
lenguaje verbal voz aguda o grave
jugamos un ratito al político
me siento verdaderamente contento de
poder estar aquí con ustedes esta tarde
son un son un pueblo increíble bárbaro
segundo ejemplo
me siento verdaderamente contento de
estar aquí con ustedes
vamos a hacerles la caguama a un
municipio grande
ok que sucede voz aguda y grave la voz
aguda es una de esas voces chillonas
regularmente no están relacionadas al
liderazgo desafortunadamente son las que
ocupan los cargos de menor grado a nivel
laboral social y liderazgo la voz grave
bueno esta es una voz grave estas voces
son las que guían a las naciones a
conquistar las que guían a las naciones
a conseguir sus objetivos
esta es una voz grave ok entonces trate
traten este las niñas las mujeres no se
van a ver machorras créanme porque a
veces es que me voy a ver bien azzurra
kristen siendo así no no se ven
machorras tienen un ejemplo en la ex
primera ministro de inglaterra
vargas de tacha ella tiene una voz grave
y la fue trabajando porque ya tenía una
voz aguda vale
el lenguaje no verbal ademanes postura y
gesticulaciones qué es esto bueno todo
el tiempo estamos hablando con nuestras
manos en méxico hay algo que se llama el
t-rex cual es el síndrome tourette's
ustedes saben así
fui al cine fui con mi novio y al otro
lado y aquí y de aquí no salen
y estos son sus ademanes y de aquí no
salen
eso sería mente y rex ya saben con son
steve nash ok eso somos direct vale que
tenemos que hacer ademanes suelten si
los líderes más grandes del mundo vean
los ustedes
hay muchísimos ejemplos hoy en día por
lo regular se expanden y hagan de aquí
hacia arriba y las manos todavía a la
altura de los hombros y están hablando y
te dicen y promulgan y vociferan las
manos son muy importantes expandan las
los animales de más liderazgo se
expanden los animales más tímidos se
reprimen se retraen ok entonces tengan
mucho cuidado con eso postura bueno si
me ven caminando de esta manera y
hablando cuando ustedes no van a decir
su lenguaje verbal va a decir bueno este
tipo es un mediocre
porque porque no puede ni con su postura
corporal y nos viene a hablar de
liderazgo
baja
no tienen que ser heridos a veces cuesta
trabajo y cansa gesticulación es bueno
juguemos de nuevo al político
y estoy verdaderamente contento de estar
aquí con ustedes
segundo político estoy verdaderamente
contento de poder estar aquí con todos
ustedes que político es el honesto
la cual cualquier que esto venga venga
es el segundo por supuesto y lo vende el
segundo es más honesto porque está
siendo congruente entre lo que dice y
cómo lo dice si tú le dices a una niña
como caballero oye te amo
y si se lo dices a tu cara
porque porque no expresamos no hay esa
congruencia entre mis palabras de hacer
una palabra tan fuerte como amor y mi
gesto no dice nada es decir le estoy
mintiendo vale proceso otro tema de
detección de mentiras
lo que antes bonito no es bonito saber
cuando alguien te miente y menos cuando
es tu pareja crean de hecho todos anda
decir oye cristian que padre está eso tú
sabes cuándo te mienten no no es bonito
o gesticulaciones van a tener que
gesticular ustedes dicen que están
contentos tristes amargados frustrados
verdad con la misma cara
ustedes son estoy contento estoy enojado
estoy triste estoy aburrido todo es la
misma cara muy reconocimiento facial ok
tenga cuidado aprendan aprendan a
gesticular es increíble a qué me dedico
en pocas palabras a volver a realizar a
los seres humanos a volver seres humanos
eso es algo que me dedico se le dice
manipulación humana ojo no es malo
manipular en comunicación lo que es malo
es para que lo utilizas
todos los días somos manipulados todos
absolutamente todos ya sea por el
marketing en comerciales o por nuestra
propia novia o novio ya sabes
ya te vas acá
ok ese tonito esa forma de decir es ya
manipulación o que todo el tiempo
estamos manipulando
venga emotividad motivos como ser un
buen comunicador es la emotividad el
secreto de la manipulación humana niños
niñas se llaman neuronas espejo las
neuronas espejos son estas neuronas que
nos genera la empatía que hace que
cuando vemos a alguien a la cara y
sonreímos ellas sonreían con nosotros si
sacamos la lengua ellas nos sacan la
lengua hay una conexión y no es magia no
es algo astrofísico no no no es
biológico se activan estas neuronas
espejo y ustedes pueden manipular a
quien quieran cómo se logra esto siendo
congruentes entre lo que dicen y cómo lo
dice expresen sean emotivos si están
contentos apple es la alegría vomité de
la cara a la alegría las personas
vomitan se la alegría si están enojados
pues entonces se enojen se pero que la
emoción sea congruente que es evidente a
quienes los ven y los escuchan así es
cómo manipulan a todos
por eso me contratan los políticos para
manipular a las masas
ok
distintas caras que estipulen no tengan
miedo
ventajas confianza evidentemente
confianza se van a sentir más seguros
van a sentirse que todo lo puede aunque
no sea así pero es bello sentirse que
aquí enfrente en su trabajo o con su
familia hablan con confianza eso se
proyecta y crean que se siente muy bien
vale proyección de liderazgo supongo que
aquí todos quieren ser líderes quien de
aquí quiere ser un diversión esto
levante su mando por favor
bueno la mayoría quiero hablar de
líderes quiere ser líder necesitan
confianza tienen confianza
si lo que no se ve
empieza en sí bueno tal vez
bueno entonces
somos más sociables y definitivamente la
gente quiere rodearse más con nosotros
sobre salimos en el trabajo ojo también
generamos envidias de ser buenos
comunicadores no crean que todo es miel
sobre ojuelas y ositos cariñositos
aventando gomitas por un arcoiris de
banano también generamos envidias porque
hay personas que quieren ser como
ustedes que se quieren comunicar de esa
manera y como no si son ustedes los que
llaman la atención todo el mundo todo el
mundo quiere ser el rey el alfa de la
manada pero no todos soportan la crítica
ni la envidia
así que tengan en cuenta liga arteal te
puedes llegar a ti pues porque lo que
una mujer o un hombre como nos liga como
nos ligamos entre nosotros es la
emotividad no es lo mismo niños niñas
que un hombre o una mujer te diga oye te
amo porque eres el amor de mi vida pues
like no gracias muchas gracias que te
diga oye alejandra
de app
porque eres
lo más espectacular
que podrá encontrar en este planeta
[Música]
denle pausa a sus palabras no vengan
porque tenemos poco tiempo para mí
hablar 18 minutos es hablar 3 minutos
entonces pues así como que como un tren
descarrilado pero después si quieren
organizamos algo más pero de verdad
gesticulan gesticulan y sean emotivos
vale
biológica cortisol contra testosterona
el cortisol la hormona del estrés las
personas inseguras que viven todo el
miedo con miedo nuevo esto me da miedo
acercarme no se lo digo como se lo digo
y si me regaña y se me pega y se me
corren ok
hay consecuencias biológicas y esa es la
generación del cortisol esa hormona nos
riega la vida hay una frase que dice
quiero enamorarme para adelgazar de peso
para para bajar de peso porque dicen eso
porque entras en un estado cuando te
rompen el corazón donde generas mucho
cortisol y el cortisol te consume
entonces tengan cuidado con eso al revés
con la testosterona la testosterona te
vuelve ese león ese macho de traigan a
todas
yo puedo con todas este y las mujeres yo
también puedo contados no eso es lo que
generamos con testosterona testosterona
esta hormona nos hace sentir más seguros
nos hace ser más arriesgados y decir
aquí yo ya saben no no lo digo por
respeto a ti pero ya sabe somos más
sexys todas las personas que están aquí
enfrente hablando en público son mucho
más sexys todas todas las niñas se fijan
en el tipo que está hablando en una
conversación todos los hombres nos
fijamos en esa mujer que se expande que
habla que proyecta que no tienen miedo
de alzar la voz
ojo la voz es muy importante un dato que
no les dije la voz no están gritando y
hay muchos políticos que me dicen
cristian es que ya estoy gritando no me
estás gritando por primera vez en tu
vida estás hablando con un ser humano
normal por primera vez que escucho
entonces no están gritando vale tengan
mucho cuidado con eso sean sexys eso nos
genera más atracción sexual
hay una frase con la que quiero dejarlos
se dice que sabe pensar pero no sabe
expresar lo que piensa está en el mismo
nivel del que no sabe pensar de pericles
que quiere decir esto
niños niñas por más diplomados que
tengan más doctorados que tengan no les
garantiza que ustedes sean capaces de
ser buenos comunicadores ni aquí ni con
sus familias ni con sus novias ni bien
su grupo social no se los garantiza un
documento no les garantiza nada de eso
nada absolutamente nada si no saben
pensar si no saben expresar sus ideas
pareciera que aunque hayan estudiado mil
años en harvard
que no sabe nada por eso hay tantos
hablando de política tantos políticos
que nos da una flojera impresionante
escuchar porque ellos mismos son los que
nos incitan a la flojera no son buenos
comunicadores y en méxico la comunidad
política no es buena comunicadora no lo
es
lo que quiero decirles como punto final
es viva
viva hay una cosa que si no se han dado
cuenta que se llama peinar esas venas
tiene su sangre esas venas por esas
venas recorre su vida por esas venas
recorre el pulso de su corazón por esas
venas si ustedes no son los primeros en
darles vida y en hacer que toda esa
sangre fluya pues entonces ante los
demás prácticamente están muertos no
tengan miedo de comunicarse lo que
tienen que hacer es simplemente fijarse
en lo que quieren decir sin importar lo
que los demás digan no es importante lo
que más digan lo que es importante es
que ustedes tienen una sola vida y que
si no decimos en esta vida lo que
queremos decir y cómo lo queremos decir
entonces nunca lo vamos a decir si
ustedes creen que en esa caja cremados
si ustedes creen que en esa caja hecha
esqueletos van a poder seguir expresarse
no no lo van a hacer simplemente allí
vamos a estar muertos y no vamos a poder
decir lo que queríamos decir así que
esto está aquí háganlo vivir hagan que
corra su sangre comuníquense sin miedo
sin que la crítica
sin que les importe si están flacos
gorditos chaparritos altos eso no es
importante que no les importe si se nos
fue una idea aquí enfrente aquí enfrente
los errores son tan grandes como ustedes
quieran hacerlo o tan pequeños como
ustedes quieran hacerlos pero no se
fijen en los errores cuando ustedes se
comunican fíjense únicamente en lo que
quieren decir y como no quieren decir
sean emotivos hagan latir a esta cosa
que se llama corazón expongas ante los
demás se nos pueden lastimar se los juro
que si se los juro y les prometo que se
nos van a lastimar pero cuando mueran
van a decir que viaje tan espectacular
[Aplausos]
[Música]